hey guys welcome back and I'm here to
tell you today about what happened
during the Warriors den dead stream for
the fourth week this time now this is
actually a pretty good stream they're
very straight forward for all other
questions there's a lot of balance
changes and very good balance changes
and some things that are dressing in the
near future so let's get right into that
so the first thing I'm going to be
talking about is the balance changes to
three different characters which are
peacekeeper war Lord and law brainer
peacekeeper God had changed to her zone
attack it moves it's more treated like a
light attack so that it she is blocked
if that attack is blocked it is more
punishable that way and it moves the
move starts earlier so it's a lot easier
to you know kind of react to it and
block it her sidestep strike we're
basically she dashes forward and then
stabs you or she'll go to the left or
right and then jab you is now reduced to
15 instead of 20 damage the recovery
time was increased so that if she gets
blocked from using one of those sidestep
attacks it takes longer fur to strike
again her past attack is now 30 damage
instead of 25 the reason they're
increasing the damage on this is that a
lot of players don't use it they utilize
the light attack spam and the sidestep
strikes the way that Ubisoft deb deb's
did this is that they looked at the data
for the damage done with each attack
they notice that the report damage or
the amount of damage that people are the
amount of times people use the repulsive
wasn't as much as they use to set aside
step strikes so they decided to decrease
the size of drugs and increase their the
repost attack that's what they're
thinking was I think these are some
pretty good changes there are still more
so let's get back into that the light
attack spam has yet to be addressed
though but they do want to see that
these previous buffs and nerves is how
they affect her and see how she's played
then they're going to decide whether or
not to fix it I do believe that they
should fix it anyway that's just my
personal opinion also I need to mention
that all the characters all 12
characters are getting a rework they are
just not being stated at all at once
this stream consisted of the three
characters i mentioned next three are
going to be Kent's a conqueror and I
believe Berserker next one should also
be a roti and Rader
and the others in the next coming weeks
the next character up is warlord warlord
got an increased cost of stamina to his
head but during 12 to 15 so it costs a
lot more stamina when you use it because
a lot of people are spamming it this
also it also increased the Dodge window
so it's a lot easier to invade the head
butt and if he misses the head but it
increases the recovery time so that he
can't attack immediately right away so
this is a pretty pretty decent nerf the
warlord I don't play warlord at all so I
don't know if this is going to be very
effective effective or not that you also
can't trigger headbutt from full guard
stance you have to actually physically
block it from that side and then do the
head but you can't just go full guard
blocks stance and then activate it and
then the last character that was
addressed with La Brea la bringer got so
many [ __ ] box it's unbelievable if
you do the long arm attack which is when
he picks you up and flips you over you
get a guaranteed side heavy attack and
the person cannot block it if they're on
the floor because obviously when you
flip them over the way on the floor but
if you go for the top heavy they can
still block at you they have enough time
to if you go for the side attack they
cannot block it swift justice chain
attack which is the heavy light heavy
that chain attack is is now faster on
the light attack the light attack is now
faster by 200 milliseconds the impelling
riposte attack is now guaranteed after
you pair your opponent the law burners
own attack damage now this 25 instead of
20 and it has hyper armor for any of you
Dark Souls players you know exactly what
this means but basically it's like shugo
key if he if law bringer does is it does
his little zone attack he cannot be
interrupted so regardless of how many
times he's hit he will still go along
with the move his normal chain attack
books chapter verse and judge jury and
executioner are faster and do a lot more
damage the unblockable and judge jury
and executioner not just 45 damage
instead of 30 and all of his regular
light and heavy attacks do more damage
and they used to I feel like this is a
very big buff to la bringer he is
practically god tier of there some I'm
happy to see that he's getting a lot of
bucks I was very bad with him and much
as I didn't really like him the much is
because I was bad
but i think i'm going to start using
while doing a lot more as i stated
before Kent's a berserker and conquer
are getting changes but they don't want
to throw everything at us at once
they're trying to see how the changes
work and then they're going to basically
add these in later and see how you know
the original ones affect us or not all
the changes are going to be coming to PC
and then Council in the next two weeks
depending on when they are like two
weeks after that pc gets it i think this
is a bit too long in my opinion well
it's however they want to do their work
boosts are actually going to take a lot
longer to get not a lot longer but
they're going to take a bit longer to
collect in skirmish an elimination by
one second longer which could basically
mean life or death as some instances and
Ubisoft finally Ubisoft has acknowledged
the rage quitter problem and they're
testing it right now but it won't be
there anytime soon the problem is that a
lot of people are rage quitting and then
it basically gives basically an unfair
advantage or the game will lag out
because of because of that so they're
fixing and they're focusing on these
problems as well as long as obvious as
the connectivity issues have arised as
well they're always going to be focusing
on that as well this is probably one of
the best streams Ubisoft has ever done
for this warriors then I liked all the
straightforward answers none of the
weird like oh we're going to do this and
we're working on it answers they're
really straightforward communicating
with us this is very good I like the way
that Ubisoft has done this want to hear
your guys opinion some of these boxes
and nerves whether you think this was
that these were needed these weren't
needed anything in the comments below
would be nice if you did like the video
please like it please click that like
button if you're new to this channel hit
the subscribe button always posting out
the dead streams I was doing the fall on
our content and I'll see you all later
boys and peace out